[Music]
[Applause]
as the war draws closer to the ethiopian
capital the defense of addis ababa is
waged in unconventional ways
at youth and community centers across
the city
[Applause]
religious leaders tell residents they're
ready to go and fight
while aging veterans seem confident of
victory over the leaders of the region
of tigre
and there are sounds of defiance in a
city where many feel isolated
here a former general delivers a threat
with a reference to a colonial foe
foreign then brand new recruits are
brought to the front of the hall
20 men and women who will join
government forces to fight the rebel
tplf and in the district of erada they
are embraced as saviors
you are
going to the front with
very little training
[Music]
[Music]
that's exactly what ethiopia's prime
minister abby ahmed wants to hear
he's now informed the nation via social
media that he's going to the front where
he will personally lead the army
leaving the business of government to
others
and he's asked ethiopians to join him in
what he calls the battle to save the
nation
abby's announcement has come as a
surprise a shock really to the people of
addis ababa because many people here
thought the government was winning the
war
but the reality is different the rebels
are just 140 miles away and the prime
minister has made what sounds like a
final call to arms
some of abbey soldiers are now prisoners
of war
and the tigrayans have been parading
them before the cameras
there are reports that some 16 000 may
be held by the tplf
these pictures part of a propaganda war
which is fought with equal ferocity
for the people of addis ababa history
seems to be repeating itself with
another rebel army threatening to invade
and many here have sought sanctuary in
their faith god will save us
well god is will be with us if we go to
church
god will save you
we are 100 percent sure god will save
state is protecting us
foreign countries like france and canada
and neighboring sudan have told their
citizens to leave immediately
but the people of this city must stay
and wait
john sparks sky news in addis ababa